if you see the phrase ten items or less
in a supermarket and immediately cringe
and complain that it should be ten items
or fewer well you are not going to like
this video
pretty much every academic linguist
those at study and analyze languages
count themselves as descriptivists this
means that they describe languages but
they never say that they should be a
certain way on the other side are the
prescriptivists who prescribe in much
the same way as a doctor prescribes a
suppository they're the people who say
that this is how language should be
dammit and how on earth are we supposed
to communicate Clery irony roll back a
little how on earth are we supposed to
communicate clearly when people keep
blurring things and using slide I've not
got much time for prescriptivists they
say that this way to speak is correct
and this way is incorrect
to which I say bollocks I welcome this
rule as long as the recipient pays
attention to the message and isn't
trying to decipher what you're saying
then talk however the hell you want that
doesn't mean that you should start
sprinkling apostrophes all over the
place or not carrying a damn for
spelling rules and that s are you
writing they'll get in the way of people
understanding your message clearly but
it does mean that the grammar police out
there can absolutely go and do what John
Atwater describes English as a glorious
bastard language the British Isles have
been invaded so many times by so many
different groups through history that
we've got words and grammar and spelling
rules from all over the place from
French from Latin from Old Norse from
Dutch then you've got all the words that
we've taken on and welcomed more
recently every language does this but
not all of them will commit there is for
example academy false aids the french
academy they are the authority on the
french language
and though it's not legally binding
their view is very much respected by the
government and press members of the
academy are known as immortals no
seriously they they call themselves
immortals they aim to halt the converse
ization of French to the point where
they simply announced one day in 2003
that from now on the French word for
email will be create and in 2013 and as
suddenly the official French word for
hashtag would be Modi ace or sharp word
you can probably guess how much each of
those words is actually getting used in
France pretty much all major languages
have an academy apart
English which has gone along just fine
language changes regularly and often the
Oxford English Dictionary hailed as the
authority on the English language is
descriptive not prescriptive and that is
really important they'll tell you what's
considered correct but if popular
opinion changes so will they and so
should you
so the next time some peasant complains
that's not what the dictionary says well
then the dictionary probably needs
updating at least there's does next time
we'll have a look at some people who've
tried to force changes into English and
see exactly how well that went